hey everyone this is lucy as you can
tell from the title of this video i'll
be giving away four aws certification
vouchers as a celebration for reaching
20 000 subscribers on this channel now
before i explain the exact details of
how to enter this giveaway i just wanted
to say a massive thank you to everyone
who has watched my videos over the past
one and a half years i am super grateful
for all your comments and messages and
i'm really looking forward to making
more videos to help people build their
technical skills and land a job in the
cloud computing industry okay so here
are the four exam vouchers i'll be
giving away two vouchers for the aws
solutions arctic associate certification
and two vouchers for the aws cloud
practitioner certification to enter all
you have to do is follow these three
steps number one make sure you're
subscribed to this channel and have
given this video a like step number two
is comment below with what certification
exam voucher you'd like and how the
certification will help you for example
you can say i would like the aws cloud
practitioner certification voucher it
will help me on my goal of landing a job
in the cloud industry step number three
is to fill in the form linked in the
video description below this is for me
to have your email address and details
so i can notify you if you've been
selected as a winner so four winners
will be selected for these exam vouchers
on the 20th of august which is around
three weeks from now so make sure you
keep an eye out for the announcement and
just as a disclaimer this giveaway is
completely free and is not affiliated
with youtube or aws in any way these
vouchers actually cost me a total of 500
us dollars and i want to offer them to
you for free because i know a lot of you
who watch my videos are interested in
starting your cloud learning journey but
find it hard to afford the exam fee so
best of luck everyone thank you all
again so much for your continued support
and i'll see you soon bye for now
you